لن نتعاون لا تفته اسرائيل تقولها في وجه
الحقيقه بها تتحدى كل مسعد لتحقيق النزيه
في اغتيال زميلتنا الراحله شيرين ابو
عاقله هذه المره تحتاج نبره تل ابيب مع
واشنطن
لن يتم تحقيق مع جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
على يد الاف بي اي ولا على يد اي جهه
اجنبيه
عبر القنوات الملائمه
يشير الى تحقيق الاف بي اي بوصفه خطا
جسيما وتدخل في شؤون تل ابيب الداخليه
انه امر غير مسبوق تلاحظ وكاله اصل الشيتد
بريس ان يفتح تحقيق امريكي بشان ما توصف
بدوله حديثه وان يكون ففي واشنطن مشرعون
ظلوا ينبهون الى ان شيرين ابو عاقله لها
الحق بوصفها مواطنه امريكيه في الحمايه
الكامله التي توفر للمواطنين ممن يعيشون
في الخارج
والان بدا لاعضاء في الكونجرس ان تحقيق
الامريكي يشكل خطوه الاولى طال انتظارها
نحو المسائله ذاك عينه ما تبغيه عائلته
شيرين
بمنع تكرار هذا الشيء عم بنشوف جرائم في
فلسطين من غير محاسبه ومتمه انه هذا
التحقيق بيكون بدايه محاسبه
في حق الفلسطيني
جلاء الحقيقه بما يستتبعه من محاسبه ما
تزال تنشله اسره شيرين الكبرى من زملاء
المهنه
تقول منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود انها ترحب
باي مبادره من شانها تحقيق العداله في
قضيه شيرين ابو عاقله بما فيها التحقيق
الامريكي
اما المعهد الدولي للصحافه فيحث الولايات
المتحده على جعل التحقيق شاملا ومستقلا
وموثقا به
على الارجح الى مقصده بالرغم من الرفض
الاسرائيلي الذي توقعه كثيره
الاحتلال ترفض وتشكك في كل تحقيق في
ملابسات اغتيالها ليست هي من تديرها
تحقيقات الجزيره ووسائل اعلام الغربيه
ومنظمات دوليه انتهى جميعها الى ان شيريهن
قتلت برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي اثناء
تغطيتها اقتحام مدينه جنين فيما الماضي
اما اسرائيل فقطعت قبل شهرين سلسله
رواياتها المتضاربه
اثارت هذه المره احتمال ان تكون شيرين
قتلت برصاص اطلقه احد جنودها لكن كما قالت
بطريق الخطا